[Music]
in this video I introduce you to GC
rescue 2 the GC rescue 2 can help you
recover Google computer engine or GC
verto machine or VM that cannot be
accessed remotely such as through SSH or
remote desktop who has never had
problems with remote access to a server
after repoting a vam whether from a plan
manance or an expected crash when that
happen to a physical server you can just
access and restart the server directly
it's simple for a cloud-based VM things
start to become a little more
complicated how will I S my server if
not available remotely let's have a
quick look at different ways to recover
a gcvm in the traditional approach we
typically use life raft instance to Res
both
VMS create a temporary VM make a copy of
the boot dis attach the copy of the
secondary nearly created VM fix any
issues detach the dis and replace with
old fult
dis with this approach there are some
disadvantage one of the advantage with
this approach is that you can
troubleshoot the VM while it's still
running since you are troubleshoot a cup
of the dis you don't need to stop your
VM on the other hand with GC rescue we
don't need to create a whole new VM GC
res will simply attach a small working
boot dis to your
VM by changing the boot order you can
access default dis as a secondary dis as
it's not being used to boot DVM and
since DVM was working before you don't
need any extra resource just access the
VM via SSH and that's it so what is GC
rescue GC rescue is a common aligning
tool that enables you to put GC VMS in
rescue mode GC rescue can be useful in a
handful of situations here are a few
example use case resc VM that has lots
connectivity that is we are unable to
connect to the VM using normal methods
like SSH or remote desktop protocol
known as RDP fix the boot process of a
VM for example boot loaders caral
updates or even dis partition errors
that can cause boot issues Resto
passwords such as situations where admin
user has lost a local password retri
files for ANM which cannot be booted Us
in normal ways for backup purpose be
aware GC Rask is maintained and
supported by the open source Community
is not part of Google Cloud Suite of
products here is how you can use a GC
resk it's straight from Google console
the web based UI from Google Cloud on
Google Cloud console open open Cloud
shell terminal use a pip to install GC
rescue to execute GC rescue you need to
have at least the VM name and the Zone
in which the VM is
created let's demonstrate how to use GC
R to fix a VM with boot
errors here is a VM test demo created in
the zone Europe Central 2
a oops I'm not able to connect via
anymore let's look at the serial log
message and see if you can find any
clue wait what is that it seems ofm
fails to open the inrd file this can
happen if the file is either corrupted
or
incomplete let's create the
file for this let's connect the VM test
them in in rescue mode in Cloud showell
terminal run GC rescue confirm you want
to boot the VM in rescue mode the whole
process may take a while it will depend
on how big your boot dis is great it got
completed now when you try to SS AG into
the VM again in the cloud console it
will automatically connect you in rescue
mode next you can take all the steps
necessary to fix your booty issue
remember your original disc is the
secondary one everything you write on
the rescue disc will be lost once the VM
is configured back to normal mode again
when your VM is rescue mode you'll note
some hints that your VM is on Rescue
mode like the dash Rask added to the
host
name theault dis will be mounted
automatically on the MC
route if default dis is not mounted
autom automatically use the command l b
to identify the dis and mount it
manually to access its contents navigate
to Thea disk we can see that the in Rd
file is amped to fix that let's simply
recreate
it everything looks fine now let's asit
SSH and restore the VM to boot from its
original disc by Runing the same command
again in Cloud shell
GC rescue ask you to confirm again if
you want to continue the
operation it looks good let's now try to
access the VM
again congratulations we have a
successfully fixed DVM and it is spr to
use stay tuned for more tips on how GC
RK can help you with other scenarios for
more information about this resk check
out this documentation thanks for
watching
[Music]